the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so remember less time on Tuesday we
learnt about the chain rule and so for
example we saw that if we have a
function that depends sorry on three
variables X Y Z but XYZ themselves
depends depend on some variable T then
you can find a formula for DW DT by
writing down W sub X DX DT plus W sub y
dy DT plus W sub Z DZ DT and the meaning
of that formula is that well the change
in W is caused by changes in XY and z XY
and Z change at rates DX DT dy DT DZ DT
and this causes the function to change
accordingly using in terms of a puzzled
well the partial derivatives tell you
how sensitive W is to changes in each
variable okay so we are going to just
rewrite this in a new notation so I'm
going to write this in a more concise
form as gradient of W dot product with
the velocity vector dr/dt where so the
gradient of W is a vector formed by
putting together all of the partial
derivatives okay so it's the vector with
components the partials and of course
it's a vector that depends on x y&z all
right these guys depend on X Y Z so it's
actually one vector for each point X Y Z
you can talk about the gradient
of the w at some point XYZ so at each
point it gives you a vector that
actually is what we will call later a
vector field but we'll get we'll get
back to that later and dr/dt is just the
velocity vector DX DT dy DT DZ DT ok so
the new definition for today is the
definition of a gradient vector and our
goal will be to understand a bit better
what does this vector mean what does it
measure and what can we do with it but
you see that in terms of information
content it's really the same information
that's already in the partial
derivatives or in the differential
so yes and they should say of course you
can also use the gradient in other
things like approximation formulas and
so on it's just so far it's just
notation it's a way to live writings but
so here's the first cool property of the
gradient so I claim that the gradient
vector is perpendicular to the level
surface corresponding to setting the
function W equal to a constant okay so
if I draw a contour plot of my function
so I'm going to actually forget about Z
because I want to draw a two variable
contour plot so say I have a function of
two variables x and y then maybe it has
some contour plot and I'm saying if I
take the gradient of a function at this
point X Y so I will have a vector well
if I draw a vector on top of a contour
plot it's going to end up being
perpendicular to the level curve at this
point same thing if I have a function of
three variables then I can try to draw
its contour plot because I can't really
do it because the contour plot would be
you know living in space with XY and Z
but it would be a bunch of level
surfaces and the gradient vector would
be a vector in space that vector is
perpendicular to the level surfaces so
let's try to see that on a couple of
examples
so let's do a first example let's do
things you know what's the easiest case
let's take a linear function of XY and Z
so I will take W equals a 1 times X plus
a 2 times y plus FA times Z well so
what's the gradient of this function
well first component will be a1 that's
partial W partial X then a - that's
partial W partial Y and a 3 partial W
partial Z ok now what are the level
surfaces well if I set W equal to some
constant C that means I look at the
points where a 1 X plus a 2 y plus FA Z
equals C what kind of surface is wet
it's a plane and we know how to find a
normal vector to this plane just by
looking at the coefficients
so it's a plane with normal vector
exactly this gradient and in fact you
know in a way this is the only case you
need to check because of linear
approximation if you replace a function
by its linear approximation that means
you will replace the level surfaces by
the tangent planes and then you will
actually end up in this situation but
maybe that's not very convincing so
let's do another example
so let's do a second example let's say
we look at the function X square plus y
squared ok so now it's a function of
just two variables because that way
we'll be able to actually draw a picture
for you ok so what are the level sets of
this function well they're going to be
circles right W equals C is a circle x
squared plus y squared equals C so I
should say so save a level curve is a
circle so the contour plot looks
something like that
now what's the gradient vector well the
gradient of this function so partial W
partial X is 2x and partial u partial Y
is 2y so let's say I take a point X
comma Y and I try to draw my gradient
vector so here at X Y so I have to
devolve a vector 2x 2y what does it look
like well it's going in that direction
it's parallel to the position vector for
this point it's actually twice the
position vector so I get it goes no or
less like this what's interesting to us
is it is perpendicular to this circle
okay
so it's a general feature if you let me
show you more examples
oops not the one I want so I don't know
if you can see it so well well hopefully
you can so here I have a contour plot of
a function and I have a blue vector
that's the gradient vector at the pink
point on the plot so you can see I can
move the pink point and the gradient
vector of course changes because the
gradient depends on x and y but what
doesn't change is that it's always
perpendicular to the level curves
anywhere where I am
my gradient stays perpendicular to the
level curve ok is that convincing is
that visible even for people who can see
blue ok so
okay so we have a lot of evidence but
you know let's try to prove the theorem
because it will be interesting so first
of all so any questions about the
statement the examples yes
ah very good question where does the
gradient vector why is the gradient
vector perpendicular in one direction
rather than the other so we'll see the
answer to that in a few minutes but let
me just tell you immediately to decide
which side it's pointing to it's always
pointing towards higher values of the
function okay and we'll see that maybe
in about half an hour so well let me say
actually points towards higher values of
W any other questions I don't see any
questions so okay so let's try to prove
this theorem at least this part of the
theorem we are not going to prove that
just yet that will come in a while
so well maybe we want to understand
first what happens if we move inside the
level curve okay so let's imagine that
we are taking a moving point that stays
on the level curve or on the level
surface and then we know well what
happens is that the function stays
constant but we can also know how
quickly the function changes using the
chain rule up there
so maybe the chain rule will actually be
the key to understanding how the
gradient vector and a motion on the
level surface relate so let's take a
curve R equals R of T that stays inside
well maybe I should say on the level
surface W equals C so let's think about
what that means so just to get you used
to this idea I'm going to draw a level
surface of a function of three variables
okay so it's some surface given by the
equation W of X Y Z equals some constant
C and so now I'm going to have a point
on that and is going to move on that
surface so I will have you know some
time at red curve that lives on this
surface so the question is what's going
to happen at any given time well the
first observation is that the velocity
vector what can I say about the velocity
vector of this motion it's going to be
tangent to the level surface right if I
move on a surface then at any point my
velocity is tangent to the curve but if
it's tangent to the curve then it's also
tangent to the surface because the curve
is inside
surface so okay it's getting a bit
cluttered and they should have a bigger
picture let me do that right away here
so I have my level surface the body we
could see I have a curve on that and at
some point I'm going to have a certain
velocity so the claim is that the
velocity V equals V R DT is tangent to
the level W equals C because it's
tangent to the curve and the curve is
inside the level okay now what else can
we say well we have the chain rule to
tell us how the value of W changes so by
the chain rule we have the W DT so the
rate of change of the value of W as I
move along this curve is given by the
dot product between the gradient and the
velocity vector
and so when maybe I can rewrite it as
number never W sorry del W dot V and
that should be well what should it be
what happens to the value of W as T
changes well it stays constant because
we are moving on a curve that curve
might be complicated but it stays always
on the level W equals C so it's zero
because the value of T equals C which is
a constant ok is that convincing yeah
okay so now if we have a dot product
with zero that tells us that these two
guys are perpendicular so
so the gradient vector is perpendicular
to V okay that's a good start we know
that the gradient is perpendicular to
this vector tangent that's tangent to
the level surface what about other
vectors tangent to the level surface
well in fact I could use any curve drawn
on the level W equals C so I could move
really any way I wanted on that surface
in particular I claim that I could have
chosen my velocity vector to be any
vector tangent to the surface okay so
let's write this this is true for any
curve one of be physical any motion on
the level surface W equals C so that
means V can be any vector tangent to the
surface tension to the level C for
example click on one more picture
ok so I have my level surface so I'm
growing more and more levels and they
never quite look the same from it and I
have a point and at this point I have
the tangent plane to the level surface
this is tangent plane to the level then
if I choose any vector in that tangent
plane let's say trues and know when that
goes in that direction then I can
actually find a curve that goes in that
direction and stays on the level so here
that would be a curve that somehow goes
from the right to the left and because
it has to end up going up or something
like that okay so given any vector
tangent
let's call Detective V tangent to the
level we get that the gradient is
perpendicular to V so the gradient is
perpendicular to this vector tangent to
this curve but also to you know any
vector I can probe at Stan joined to my
surface so what does that mean well that
means the gradient is actually
perpendicular to the tangent plane or to
the surface at this point so the
gradient is perpendicular
and well here I've Illustrated things
with a three-dimensional example but
really it works the same if you have
only two variables then you have a level
curve it has a tangent line and the
gradient is perpendicular to that line
okay any questions nope
okay
so let's see that's actually pretty neat
because there's a nice application of
this which is to try to figure out now
we know actually how to find the tangent
plane to anything pretty much
okay
so let's see so let's say that for
example I want to find the tangent plane
to the surface with equation let's say X
square plus y squared minus Z squared
equals 4 at the point 2 1 1 let me write
that so how do we do that
well one way that we already know if we
solve this for Z so we can write Z
equals function of x and y then we know
tangent plane approximation for the
graph of a function Z equals some
function of x and y but that doesn't
look like it's the best way to do it
okay the best way to do it now that we
have a gradient vector is actually to
directly say oh we know the normal
vector to this plane the normal vector
will just be the gradient oh I think I
have a cool picture to show soon ok so
that's what it looks like ok so here you
have the surface x square plus y square
minus z square equals 4 that's called a
hyperbola it because it looks like what
you get when you spin a hyperbola around
an axis and here's its tangent plane at
the given point so it doesn't look very
tangent because it crosses the surface
but it's really I mean if you think
about it you'll see that's really the
plane but approximating the surface in
the best way that you can at this given
point it is really the tangent plane
so how do we find this plane well you
can put it in a computer but that's not
exactly you know how you would look for
it in the first place
so the way to do it is that we compute
the gradient so the gradient of what
well the gradient of this function okay
so so if you'd say this is the level set
W equals four where W is x squared plus
y squared minus Z squared and so we know
that the gradient of this well what is
it 2x then 2y and then negative 2z so at
this given point I guess we add x equals
2 so that's 4 and then y&z are 1 2
negative 2 and that's going to be the
normal vector to the surface or to the
tangent plane and that's one way to
define the tangent plane right it has
the same normal vector as the surface
but when we define the normal vector to
the surface if you prefer being
perpendicular to the surface means that
you're perpendicular to its tangent
plane okay so the equation is well 4x
plus 2y minus 2z equals something where
something is well we should just plug in
that point we'll get 8 plus 2 minus 2
looks like we'll get 8 and of course we
could simplify by dividing everything by
2 but it's not very important here
okay so now if you have a surface given
by an evil equation and the point on the
surface where you know how to find the
tangent plane to the surface at that
point okay any questions
okay let me give just another reason why
another way that we could have seen this
so I claim in fact we could have done
this without the gradient we know using
the gradient in somehow it is guised way
so here's another way so the other way
to do it would be to start with a
differential okay
DW well it's pretty much the same
content but let me write it as a
differential DW is 2x DX minus 2 wide SR
plus 2y dy minus 2 Z DZ so at the given
point at 2 1 1 this is 4 DX plus 2 dy
minus 2 DZ now if we want to change this
into an approximation formula we can we
know that the change in W is
approximately equal to 4 Delta X plus 2
Delta Y minus 2 Delta Z okay so when do
we stay on the level surface well we
stand the level surface when W doesn't
change so when this becomes 0 okay now
what does this approximation sign mean
well it means that for small changes in
X Y Z this guy will be close to that guy
it also means something else
remember this approximation formulas
they are linear approximation we mean
that we replace the function actually
buy some closest linear formula that
will be nearby and so in particular if
we set this equal to zero instead of
approximately zero it means we'll
actually be moving on the tangent plane
to the level set if you want setting
equalities and approximations means that
we replace the function by its tangent
approximation
so
okay so
the level corresponds to Delta W equals
zero and it's tangent plane corresponds
to 4 Delta X plus 2 Delta Y minus 2
Delta Z equals 0 that's what I'm trying
to say basically and what Delta X well
that means it's the change in X so
what's the change in X here that means
well we started with x equals 2 and we
move to some other value X so that's
actually X minus 2 right that's how much
X has changed compared to 2 & 2 times y
minus 1 minus 2 times Z minus 1 equals 0
that's the equation of a tangent plane
it's the same equation as the one over
there these are just two different
methods to get it okay so this one
explains to you what's going on in terms
of approximation formulas this one goes
you know right away to the answer by
using the gradient vector so in a way
with this one you have you don't have to
think nearly as much but you can use
either one okay questions
No okay so let's move on with let's move
on to a new topic which is another
application of a gradient vector and
that is directional derivatives okay so
let's say that we have a function of two
variables x and y well we know how to
compute partial W partial X or partial W
over partial Y which which measure how W
changes if I move in the direction of
the x axis or in the direction of the y
axis so what about moving in other
directions well of course we've seen
approximation formulas and so on but you
know we can still ask is there a
derivative in every direction and that's
basically yes that's the directional
derivative so these are derivatives in
the direction of I hat or J hat the
vectors that go along the X or the y
axis so
what if we move in another direction
that's in the direction of some unit
vector let's call it U okay so if I give
you a unit vector you can ask yourself
if I move in the direction how quickly
will my function change so
so let's look at the straight line
trajectory but what this would mean is I
start at some value X Y and then I have
my vector U and I'm going to move in a
straight line in the direction of U and
I have the graph of my function and I'm
asking myself how quickly those will
value change when I move on the graph in
that direction ok so let's look at a
straight line trajectory so we have a
position vector R that will depend on
some parameter which I will call s let's
see why that I soon in such a way that
the derivative is this given unit vector
u hat so why do I use s for my parameter
rather than T well it's a convention am
I'm using a moving it I'm moving at unit
speed along this line so that means that
actually I'm parameterizing things by
the distance that I've traveled along
the curve along this line so here it's
called s in the sense of you know arc
length or actually it's not again
Archy because it's a straight line so
it's the distance along the line
okay so because we are prioritizing by
distance we're just using s as a
convention just to distinguish it with
this quiz on other situations and so now
the question will be what is the WDS
what's the rate of change of W when I
move like that well of course we know
the answer because that's a special case
of a chain rule so that's how we will
actually compute it but in terms of what
it means it really means we are asking
ourselves we start at a point and we
change the variables in a certain
direction which is not necessarily the X
of a y direction but really any
direction and then what's the derivative
in that direction okay does that make
sense as a concept kind of I see some
faces that are not completely convinced
so maybe I should show more pictures
well let me first write down a bit more
and for you something
so I just want to give you the actual
definition so sorry so first of all in
case you wonder what this is all about
so let's say that the components of our
unit vector are two numbers a and B okay
then it means that we'll move along the
line X of s equals some initial value
the point where we are actually looking
at the directional derivative plus s
times a matrix a plus a times s and y of
s equals y 0 plus B times s and then we
plug that into W
and then we take the derivative
so we have a notation for that which is
going to be the WDS with a subscript in
the direction of U to indicate you know
in which direction we're actually going
to move and that's called that's the
directional derivative
in the direction of
okay so let's see what it means
geometrically so remember we've seen
things about partial derivatives and
we've seen that the partial derivatives
are the slopes of slices of the graph by
vertical planes that are parallel to the
X or the y directions okay so if I have
a point you know at any point I can
slice the graph of my function by two
planes one that's going along the x one
along the Y direction and then I can
look at the slices of the graph this if
I can use I think so we can look at the
slices of a clip fell down here and when
we look at the tangent lines to these
slices and we look at the slope and it
gives us the partial derivative gives
you on that side we want to see also the
pointer event here okay so now similarly
the directional derivative means
actually we'll be slicing we'll be
slicing our graph by a vertical plane
it's not very colorful something more
colorful will be slicing things by a
plane that is now in the direction of
this vector U and we'll be looking at
the slope of the slice of the graph so
what that looks like here
so that's the same applied by the way
that you've used on your problem set in
case you're wondering so now I'm picking
a point on the contour plot and at that
point I slice the graph so here I'm
starting by slicing in the direction of
the x axis so in fact what I'm measuring
here by the slope of this slice is the
partial in the X direction it's really
partial F partial X which is also the
directional derivative in the direction
of X of
and now if I rotate the slice then I
have all of these planes so you see at
the bottom left I have the direction in
which I'm going does this like rotating
line that tells you in which direction
I'm going to be moving and what each
direction I have a plane and when I
slice by that plane I will get so I have
this direction here going maybe to the
southwest so that gives me a slice of my
graph by a vertical plane and the slice
has a certain slope and the slope is
going to be the directional derivative
in that direction
okay I think that's as graphic as I can
get okay any questions about that
No
okay so let's see how we compute that
guy
so let me just wipe again just in case
you want to if you don't hear me it's
the slope of the slice of the graph by a
vertical plane that contains the given
direction that's parallel to the
direction u so how do we compute it well
we can use a chain rule the chain rule
implies that the W ids is actually the
gradient of W dot product with the
velocity vector DRDs but remember we say
that we are going to be moving at unit
speed in the direction of u so in fact
that's just gradient W dot product with
a unit vector u
okay so the formula that we remember is
really DW BS in the direction of U is
gradient W dot product with u and maybe
I should also say in world this is the
component of the gradient in the
direction of U maybe that makes more
sense so for example the directional
derivative in the direction of I hat is
the component along the x axis that's
the same as indeed the partial
derivative in the x-direction things
make sense the WDS production of I hat
is sorry my vagin W dot I hat which is w
sub X over the edge to find partial W
partial X okay
now so that's basically what we need to
know to compute these guys so now let's
go back to the gradient and see what
this tells us about the gradient
I see you guys are having fun okay okay
let's do a little bit of geometry here
which should come you down so we said
the WDS in the direction of U is greater
than W value that's the same as the
length of gradient W times the length of
U well that happens to be one because we
are taking a unit vector times the
cosine of the angle between the gradient
and the given unit vector u so have this
angle theta okay that's another way of
saying we're taking the component of the
gradient in the direction of U but now
what does that tell us well let's try to
figure out in which directions W changes
the fastest in which direction it
increases the most or decreases the most
or doesn't actually change so this is
when this is going to be the largest if
I fix you if I fix a point if I set a
point then the gradient vector at that
point is given to me but question is in
which direction does it change the most
quickly well what I can change is the
direction and this will be the largest
when the cosine is 1 so this is largest
when cosine of the angle is 1 that means
the angle is 0 that means U is actually
in the direction of a gradient ok so
that's a new way to think about the
direction of a gradient the gradient is
the direction in which the function
increases for most quickly at that point
so the direction of gradient W is a
direction of fastest increase of W at a
given point and what is the magnitude of
W well it's actually the directional
derivative in that direction okay so if
I go in that direction which gives me
the fastest increase then the
corresponding slope will be the length
of a gradient and
what's the direction of fastest decays
it's going in the opposite direction
right I mean if you're my mountain and
you know that you're facing the mountain
that has no fastest increase the
direction of fastest decreases behind
you straight down okay so the minimal
value of the WDS is achieved when cosine
of theta is minus 1 that means theta
equals a hundred eighty degrees that
means U is in the direction of minus the
gradient it points opposite to the
gradient and finally when do we have DWD
s equals zero so in which direction does
the function not change well we have two
answers to that one is to just use that
formula so that's when cosine theta
equals zero that means theta equals
negative phase that means that U is
perpendicular to the gradient we have a
way to think about it a direction in
which the value doesn't change is a
direction that's tangent to the level
surface if we are not changing it means
we are moving along the level and that's
the same thing
as being tangent to the level so let me
just show that on the picture here so if
I actually show you the gradient you
can't really see it here I need to move
a bit okay so the gradient here is
pointing straight up at the point that
I've chosen now if I choose a slice
that's perpendicular you know in the
direction that's perpendicular to the
gradient so that's actually tangent to
the level curve then you see that my
slice is flat I don't actually have any
slope the directional derivative in a
direction that's perpendicular to the
gradient is basically zero now if I
rotate when the slope slowly increases
increases increases and it becomes very
large just when I'm going in the
direction of a gradient so here I have
actually a pretty big slope and now if I
keep rotating then the slope will
decrease again then becomes zero when
I'm perpendicular and when it becomes
negative it's the most negative when I'm
pointing away from the gradient and then
become zero again when I'm back
perpendicular okay so for example if I
give you a contour plot and I ask you to
draw the direction of a gradient vector
well at this point for example you would
look at the picture the gradient vector
would be going perpendicular to the
level and it will be going towards
higher values of a function and I don't
know if you can see the labels but the
thing in the middle is a minimum so it
will actually be pointing in this kind
of direction okay
so that's it for today